well this is pretty exciting I just read
that Bill and Hillary Clinton are
launching a national stadium tour
they're going to be I don't know if
they're gonna be speaking or dancing
singing I'm not sure but they're gonna
be doing a whole stadium show going
around the country packing stadiums and
I think they're stopping at a stadium
near me in fact unfortunately I'm not
gonna be able to make it because I had
plans to gouge out my own eyes that
evening but I'm sure it will be a lovely
lovely event and so I think that's
pretty wonderful all right I want to
mention two stories here very first very
briefly I got to mention this from the
headline is from CNN Heidi Heitkamp the
senator from North Dakota was ready to
vote YES on Kavanagh then she then she
watched him with the sound off that's
the headline
having been just one of three Democratic
senators to vote to confirm President
Donald Trump's first Supreme Court
nominee Niall Gorsuch height camp had
already instructed her staff to begin
drafting a statement explaining why she
thought Kavanagh deserved her vote as
well then Christine Ford came forward
and accused Kevin of sexually assaulting
her
she watched Ford's testimony it says and
then she watched Cavanaugh's and then
she watched Cavanaugh's again but this
time with the sound off it's something I
do she said we communicate not only with
words but with our body language and
demeanor I saw somebody who was very
angry who was very nervous I saw rage
and a lot of people said well of course
you're going to see rage he's being
falsely accused but it is at all times
that you're supposed to acquit yourself
with a demeanor that's becoming of the
court
Heitkamp said so she's literally
admitting that she judged him based on
how he looked when he spoke not based on
what he said not based on the content of
what he was saying but based on the mean
faces that he made as he said it that's
a set what she's saying is well well
maybe he was telling the truth
but he made mean he made mean faces
while he did so so
so I voted against him now I don't
really believe that she did that I don't
think that she watched the Kavanagh
hearing and then she watched again with
the sound off because that would be a
very strange thing to do but I think
this is her way around the kind of the
charge that she voted against an
innocent man based on false charges what
she's saying is well I wasn't even
listening to what I was just going based
on body language okay yeah you could you
can read a lot based on body language
but you have to pair that with what the
person is saying you can't you can't
just watch them devoid of context devoid
of what they're actually saying and then
make make judgments based on their body
language obviously now speaking of
feelings over facts maybe you heard
about this the astronaut scott Kelly
tweeted a Winston Churchill quote a
couple of days ago the tweet got him
into some trouble this is what the tweet
said the tweet was this is what he said
one of the greatest leaders of modern
times Sir Winston Churchill said in
victory magnanimity
I guess those days are over and that was
a very controversial
you hear that that tweet and you say wow
that's controversial I
that's some controversial stuff that's
pretty edgy there Scott Kelly now this
was I'm assuming an attack on
Republicans who were celebrating the
Cavanaugh confirmation because that's he
tweeted it when I assume that's what he
was doing there so he was agreeing with
Louie it should have made liberals happy
he was agreeing with them he was
criticizing Republicans they should have
been pleased with that but they weren't
they came after Scott Kelly apparently
on the basis that Churchill was a racist
imperialist etc so then Kelley followed
that tweet with possibly the most
embarrassing tweet ever published even
amidst the daily deluge of embarrassing
tweets this is what he
he said did MOT did not mean to offend
by quoting churchill my apologies I will
go and educate myself further on his
atrocities racist views which I do not
support my point was we need to come
together as one nation we are all
Americans that should transcend partisan
politics now there is so much to unpack
here there's so much in this one little
incident because it's emblematic of
where we are as a society so first you
see again as I frequently remark you see
the way that the left is just never
satisfied ever with anything even if you
agree with them even if you take their
side they'll still go after you if you
don't agree and take their side in the
right way using the right words avoiding
all the various different landmines that
are set out if you don't do that then
that they'll attack you and they'll
attack you in the same way that they
would have if you were all the way on
the other side on the opposite side from
them so you're either 100% on there so
we talked about this yesterday it's the
way the left operates either you're 100%
on their side with everything and in
everything that you say or you're the
enemy there's no in-between at all right
this is liberal I mean they're basically
like they're like the kid on Halloween
that goes up to the to the to the bowl
of candy left out on the porch and then
cries because it doesn't have Snickers
like you're being given free candy and
you still find a reason to whine about
actually the I think this is a better
analogy I've used this analogy before
but the modern left is very similar to
if you've ever read that book when you
were a kid the book if you give a mouse
a cookie and as you may recall in that
book that the child gives them a cookie
to a mouse and then the mouse wants a
napkin
and then the mouse wants a glass of milk
and then he keeps demanding more and
more things until finally the child is
given away all of his belongings and all
of his food and his family is left
destitute on the street and they all
starve to death well that's not exactly
how the book ends I don't read well
that's that's the but that's the idea
and honestly I'm not sure what the moral
of that story could be other than as a
cautionary tale about appealing left
appeasing leftist right I don't know
what else I mean maybe that but it could
be practical advice to don't give them
cookie to a mouse a good practical
unless it's laced with rat poison or
something but aside from that I mean
this this this is really exactly how the
left operates you give them a cookie
they want the next thing they want the
next thing they're never going to be
satiated never satisfied so that's the
first thing second I think for a moment
we should just kind of step back and
admire the sheer cowardice on display
here because it's it's almost artful
it's almost beautiful think the coward
is just how perfect the cowardice is
okay this is an astronaut okay a guy
whose job most definitely does not
depend on public approval this is this
is basically the last guy in the world
who should worry what the mob thinks it
makes no difference at all what are
people gonna do boycott NASA this guy I
mean he spends his time off the earth
he's literally off the earth in space he
should be as as far removed in a literal
sense and as unconcerned with the
opinions of the petha peanut gallery as
you could possibly be
yet he backed down and apologized why
and and look at this remarkable
turnaround so he sent the original tweet
at noon about the Churchill quote and
then he sent the next one apologizing at
7:00 p.m. so in seven hours
he went from believing the Churchill was
one of the great
it's world leaders in modern history too
believing that he was a racist guilty of
various atrocities that's and you have
to believe that Scott Kelly you know
he's quoting churchill saying is a great
world leader so he's probably thought
that churchill was a hero for his whole
life i'd imagine you don't generally go
around quoting people unless you have an
affinity for them unless you admire them
so kelly abandoned a presumably
long-held conviction that churchill was
a great world leader and ran all the way
to the other extreme labeling him a
racist guilty of atrocities in the span
of an afternoon that's all that's all
the time that it took for him to say you
know what yeah it was wrong about this
my whole life
third third thing and this gives me a
chance to underline a point that i'm
constantly making but it's an important
point never apologized to the mob this
is what happens never ever apologize to
them the problem with apologizing to the
mob is that first of all it's it's
always going to be a disingenuous
apology because nobody ever has a real
authentic moment of self-reflection
where they were real where they realized
they were wrong about something because
a bunch of idiots are screaming in their
face that's not it's possible to say
something and then reflect on it and and
later say you know what i was wrong
about that
shouldn't have said it but in order for
that to happen it requires a little bit
of reflection a little bit of right but
if people are if there's a mob screaming
in your face that's not and you and you
apologize in response to that most
likely you're apologizing just to get
them to shut up but you won't shut them
up in fact you're only gonna make it
worse on yourself because all the people
who were mad at kelly for quoting
churchill
they're still mad
and they're mad because they were never
really mad to begin with their anger is
performative as anger is so often you
know as so is so often the case with
anger and modern society its
performative they're just taking
advantage of an opportunity to jump on a
dog pile they're there they're not gonna
stop just because you apologized only
sincere people are satiated by apologies
if you're genuinely offended by
something that somebody said or did and
then they apologize then then what
you're gonna say is okay you know no
harm no foul thank you for apologizing
and then you'll move on but you notice
that that never happens there's a lot of
performative anger there are a lot of
apologies happening every day but it's
like nobody ever says apology accepted
have you noticed that apologies are
never accepted ever anymore nobody ever
accepts an apology because the people
who are being apologized to the people
that are receiving the apology they
they're they were never angry there's
there's actually not anything to
apologize for
so this is a disingenuous apology being
given to people who are disingenuously
fraudulently offended so it's it's all
it's all a charade it's all pointless
and then you just compound your problem
because what happened to Kelly is he
originally tweeted the Churchill quote
and he he had to deal with the
performative anger of the left-wing mob
and then he apologizes and they're still
angry quote unquote but now you also
have mockery and disgust from the other
side now you have people like me and
many others making fun of you for it so
all you've done is you've just you've
just you've just you've turned everybody
away you've alienated everybody which is
the way that this always works I mean
how many times do we have to see it this
how many times we have to see this play
out
before we see this is how it works when
you apologize to the mob it's not gonna
stop them
and all you do is you disappoint and and
alienate and earn the scorn of the
people who would have otherwise defended
you so don't apologize to the mob
especially if you're an astronaut and
there's absolutely no do anything to you
there's no reason to worry about what
they're saying about you but even those
of us who are not astronauts I think we
could take a lesson from this this will
be our this is our 50th such lesson in
the last month never apologize to the
mob I'm not saying never apologize
period in your life there may be times
to apologize but don't apologize to
these people don't apologize to angry
internet trolls don't apologize to these
rabid swarms of of phony charlatans
who are just really super excited for
the opportunity to be offended by
something don't don't apologize to them
and I would say that even if you really
are wrong which obviously Scott Kelly
was not wrong in quoting churchill but
even if you say something and you're
actually wrong about what you said well
still don't apologize to the mob because
they're not owed an apology what why
they owed an apology
why are a bunch of idiots on the
internet why do you if the pot they do
you didn't hurt them if there really is
an apology owed to a specific person
then go apologize to them but not to
that not to the mob whether you're wrong
or right they don't deserve it it only
encourages them
all right so that's our that's our
lesson that we can all learn for the day
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed